- You're loving this.
- I am, I cannot believe how there's
so many beautiful women.
- And you're saying no to
every single one of them.
- No one's replied to me yet.
Was it something that I said?
Was it something my mum said?
(vibrant classical music)
- I'm the mother of this gorgeous
little boy here, he's my baby.
- I feel so weird that
you're about to do this
because I don't know
if my mum knows how to
firstly, speak to women.
- What do you know about Tinder?
- So the first time I downloaded Tinder
was a couple months ago,
and the only way that could do it
was with a little help from my friends.
Some Pinot, Mother?
- I'm fairly confident
I could help Nick find
his ideal girlfriend,
he has a lot to offer.
- Like?
- I didn't think I'd be this nervous,
but I'm pretty scared right now.
- I'm going to try my best.
- So Mum, welcome to the world of Tinder.
- There you go.
There's my Facebook account.
You need to choose six photos
that you think represent me.
- And this is my account with
my default Facebook photo.
- No, you've had better days.
- That's a nice one.
- That one?
- Yes, it shows how,
you know, fun you are.
- [Tan] No.
- [Nick] Why?
- Ooh.
- What about me there giving the finger?
- No, I thought of that,
but this one I like
'cause it shows you're artistic.
- It may come to Nick's advantage
with animals in with him.
There you go, one with all your mates.
You need to let them know
that you have friends.
- [Nick] The next thing is
going to be the description.
- It might be about me as a
person or what I'm looking for.
- I'm available.
- That's all you're writing.
I'm on Tinder, so I am available.
- Yes, you are available.
- Hey, I'm looking for a
fun, sexy, outgoing lady.
My mum doesn't believe in punctuation.
- How does that sound to you?
- This is totally up to you.
- What are the ages I
should be looking for?
What do you think is appropriate?
- 19 might be a bit young.
- Gender.
- What do you think?
- Women, you're not into men, are you?
- We've had this talk, Mum.
- So we're willing to travel up to 70 Ks.
- I'm not that desperate.
- And we're on Tinder.
- [Tan] Okay, done, let's get swiping.
- Yes.
- If you like her, you click, love.
If you don't, you click, cross.
- You're wanting me to choose for you?
- Yes.
- Ha-ha. (laughing)
- To finding you someone special.
- (nervously) Yeah, hey.
- She looks too sad.
- She's outdoors, she looks
relaxed, got a bottle of water.
- She likes water.
- She's riding a horse.
- Gay four 20, what does that mean?
- Four 20 means she likes smoking weed.
- Oh that's okay.
- She's the same name as the one before.
- It's the same person.
- Oh this is her profile.
- Yeah.
- She's definitely a Gemini.
- She looks old enough to be your mother.
- Oops, can we take them, can we go back?
- No, you can't go back.
- Oh, okay.
- She's gone forever, you've
ruined my chance at marriage.
- Ah.
- She's showing her bottom.
- Ooh, she's cheeky, I
think you'd like that.
- Wow, this is fun.
- Mum's just going nope,
nope, nope, nope, nope.
- (laughs) How come we're
seeing guys as well?
- Then they're not gay though.
- I don't like it how
they do all these though.
- The mirror selfie?
- It's desperate.
- We just saw a group of men,
and their bio was, if you've
got boobs, swipe right.
- Hmm, hmm.
- Mom, she was hot.
- Do you really like that, Nick?
Okay, we'll go boobs for Nick.
- You're gonna have to
say yes to someone, Mum.
- Oh.
(mumbles)
Oh.
- Nope.
- Ooh.
- Uh.
- No.
- Hmm.
- Looks like your sister there.
- This girl has a photo with her dad
who looks like he would not
like me one bit. (laughter)
Oh, it's a match.
- Yeah.
- I have to meet her dad
now, think those, I mean.
- Oh is that your dad?
- Why would you say
that, is that your dad?
- It's just a conversation starter.
- So you just super liked
someone, that's bad.
- The other one would
have been a super like.
- Which one?
- The one that was naked.
(laughter)
Oh Jess replied.
- (gasps) What are you gonna say?
- [Tammy] I'm at work at the
moment, and my mum's visiting.
- Okay, what about that
do you think is hot?
- So my mother has
matched me with someone,
and she is going to
start a conversation now.
So how would you open up
a conversation on Tinder?
- [Nick] Hi.
- Really, hi?
- Wanna have coffee?
She said this weekend, for sure,
she said, for sure, (laughs) look.
- You need to grab their
attention, Tinder is a game.
- A game.
(laughs) Gotcha.
- Gotcha, that is so creepy.
If I walk up to a random
girl and just go, gotcha,
she's gonna get a drink with me.
- My thumb is sore. (laughs)
- I don't know whether
she's going to block me
or call the police on me.
- Well, you've got a date for me now.
- I do.
- This weekend, and I
don't know how I'm going to
explain it to her, hey, just so you know,
it wasn't me, it was my mum.
- [Tammy] No.
- [Tan] She chose you.
- You're gonna leave that out of it.
- So next step.
- Next step, that's it,
you created my profile.
- Right.
- You've pretty much creeped
the hell out of women online.
(laughs)
No one's replying to me.
- Oh, well I'm very sorry.
- You don't really talk to your parents
about what they expect from
you in terms of a partner.
It showed how high the bar
is, for me, in her eyes.
- Mum, thank you for, I should say
attempting to get my
dating life back on track.
You know me better than anyone,
so if that's what you
think represents me best,
then I guess that's the
best profile I can have.
- All right, Mum, you've made my profile.
Now it's time for me to
create your Tinder profile.
- Okay.
(suspenseful classical music)
- Nick is single because he's awkward.
- (whispers) Oh.
- [Helen] Well, you're not
that awkward, obviously.
- She's opened up with
my son is single because he's awkward.